[Musik]
irgendwo in tianjin gebirge im
nordwesten von china das basecamp der
expedition des schweizerischen
alpenclubs im dauerregen
[Musik]
fünf junge bergsteiger und ihr lied
gerät warten darauf dass die wolken sich
lichten und sie endlich den berg ihrer
träume besteigen können
[Musik]
ein monat früher die abenteurer
absolvieren einen pr termin bei einem
ihrer ausrüster sie müssen sich erst
noch daran gewöhnen im zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit zu stehen
zwei jahre lang haben sie sich auf diese
mission vorbereitet sie erlernten
spezielle klettertechnik
sie übten die rettung am berg in
gebieten die für die rega nicht
erreichbar sind
sie wurden zu einem eingeschworenen team
bereit für das große abenteuer auf der
expedition werden wir in unbekanntem
gelände sein dass wir kein kletter
büchlein geben das hilft man muss also
schnell lernen und sich anpassen man
muss ideen haben und manchmal auch
unkonventionell handeln das ist eine
wichtige fähigkeit sie alle sind
herausragende bergsteiger und sie
verfolgen ihren traum mit leidenschaft
lukas hinterberger aus gais ist 22 jahre
alt
er finanziert sich die bergsteigerei in
der teilzeit in der elterlichen käserei
arbeit und ich denke gerne scharf
funktioniert finanzieller not und tische
psyche hannes öle zu gott wenn die drei
der fünf geschafft wieder wenn auch sehr
motiviert mit der bergung der
chemielaborant sebastian brief aus
naters 21 steckt mitten in der
ausbildung zum bergführer eigentlich der
grund sieht jetzt einer von vier bin
eigentlich verlassen wenn er im winter
sechs skifahrer der schlatter zum
bericht das hold rating und der probleme
mit dem zu bringen wo man vom schultes
aus st gallen und ebenfalls 21 jahre alt
arbeite teilzeit als schreiner
dort schaffte ich natürlich für mich
super weil dafür geschaffen ist ein
guter kollege und sind da sehr viel
verständnis für den mini priorität da
macht sehr viel spaß aber ich halte es
ist einfach gutachtens geld verdienen
der 21 jährige sebastian monnet lebt bei
seinen eltern in fribourg und will nach
der expedition die ausbildung zum
bergführer beginn als bergsteiger würde
ich gerne reisen möchte auf berger in
indien und südamerika
da wo man noch ein bisschen überlegen
muss dort ist es nicht wie in chamonix
wo alle routen schon gemacht sind
nicola hoya schließlich mit renn 20
jahren der älteste im team studiert
maschinenbau und wohnt bei seinen eltern
in niederscherli per telefon aktiviert
jeder ist für sich zum trainieren hat
ist die ganze schweiz wo man im südtirol
praxis ja auch in graphit und motiviert
und haben frei ist sehr für das motorik
und hoffentlich schlauer machen
irgendwie auf material und sowie
krankheiten
das hochgebirge tian shan im grenzgebiet
zu kasachstan ist berüchtigt für sein
launisches wetter aber die wilde gegend
bietet dem team das was sie in der
schweiz nicht finden können
unbeschriebene gipfel auf über 6.500
meter höhe
[Musik]
ein paar tage vor der abreise
das expeditionsteam sucht die ausrüstung
zusammen die aus dem fundus des
schweizerischen alpenclubs mit nach
china soll
libri de gehört zu den besten
bergsteigern der schweiz
er war schon auf der ganzen welt
unterwegs und hat mit dem team für die
expedition trainiert die schweizerische
gesellschaft für geburtsmedizin stellt
der expedition zwei ärzte zur seite
roman harry und nora bands sind anpackt
tag ebenfalls nach bern gekommen um die
medizinische versorgung abschließend zu
planen es hat so ausbildungsleiter bruno
hasler bespricht mit dem team die
letzten details der expedition
und irgendwie auch das nicht passiert
und der genau nach bestem wissen und
gewissen
aber alles was mit gesetzlicher
vorgängig man quasi so hafte cruiser
klinik zu unterzeichnen also ist ein
völliger von hartmann vorgestellt jetzt
sind so viele leute
für china hat ganz ganz schwierig und
das ganz gerade bei dem sich fromme
logistik und luftig also in green gibt
es vorsichtig es gibt es nicht also wenn
der westen muss man abtransport machen
mit denen man hat bis der verträge chat
und der hand die flüge und dass sie -
wenn jetzt in das land gingen in
südamerika 17 zu zwingen
was gibt es denn wir stehen vor struktur
von rot und das ist in china im juli
abgeschaltet
nach zwei jahren vorbereitung ist der
tag der abreise gekommen
[Musik]
trotz der vorfreude fällt der abschied
nicht allen leicht
schlussendlich sie täglich frisch
alleiniger dem park und basiert auf 66
steinschlag lawine die vorschrift der
eigentlich meine gute schöne schweiz dar
wenn sie glück haben die schweiz erzielt
wir trägern oder einfach und die ablage
muss jeden fall das alles völlig offen
und doch einmal passiert anstatt sich
nicht wenn das geld nicht einfach da
haben wir immer nur immer in den augen
aber das nicht
[Musik]
ich bin einfach sehr glücklich dass er
seine leidenschaft ausleben kann zusehen
dass es ihm gut geht
er hat einen traum den er schon als
jugendlicher hatte er hat für diesen
traum gekämpft und es funktioniert wie
für eltern gibt es ehrlich gesagt nichts
schöneres
das ist wirklich außergewöhnlich dass er
seine leidenschaft folgen kann
es ist nicht selbstverständlich seinen
traum zu leben
er hat die möglichkeit ich hoffe er kann
sie noch lange nutzen
[Musik]
das team fliegt zuerst nach istanbul
nach einem kurzen zwischenhalt geht es
weiter nach almaty in kasachstan
und schließlich nach urumqi im
nordwesten von china
ich habe gar nicht so viel wirklich
vorstellen was da alles passieren und
das ist gut so also ich bin froh ich
kein kontakt darauf will ich machen und
wisse dass dies passiert aber ich da
unten wäre das wäre noch viel schlimmer
wenn ich sehe jedes mal wenn er irgendwo
gesundheit und und so strahlt
[Musik]
1 uhr 30 in der früh nach 30 stunden
reise wartet das expeditionsteam im
flughafen von urumqi auf david den
chinesischen kontaktmann sebastian der
die details der reise geplant hat fühlt
sich verantwortlich für den
reibungslosen ablauf
scheiße das ist alles chinesisch
[Musik]
er sollte uns da warten aber ich nehme
da gibt es hier wlan
offenbar geht es leichter wenn das ein
chinese macht mal schauen ob es klappt
dann schmeckt
ah ja
eine stunde später taucht da wittern
doch nachruf tut mir leid da hat es ein
missverständnis gegeben wegen der zeit
david ist für die expedition der
entscheidende mann in china ein halbes
jahr lang hat sebastian mit ihm die
einzelheiten der expedition besprochen
unzählige mails getauscht und mögliche
stolpersteine aus dem weg geräumt
kurz vor tagesanbruch erreichen sie
endlich ihre unterkunft eine
jugendherberge im zentrum der stadt
[Musik]
urumqi der hauptstadt der autonomen
provinz xinjiang
zwei tage haben die schweizer zeit um
letzte vorbereitungen zu treffen
die erste begegnung mit dem
verbindungsoffizier der chinesischen
regierung steht an
er wird die expedition auf schritt und
tritt begleiten
der gefürchtete aufpasser heißt ali ist
eine frau und leutseliger als erwartet
sie hat sich gut vorbereitet sämtliche
bewilligung für das klettern im kern
shan gebirge liegen bereits auf dem
tisch
pauli ist selbst bergsteigerin und kennt
sich mit der chinesischen bürokratie aus
und sie hat ganz und gar nicht vor die
anstands dame für die regierung zu
spielen
[Musik]
juni und sebastian fahre mit vw zum
bergsteiger verbannte autonomen provinz
chon ji an die organisation wird den
schweizern material zur verfügung stehen
vor allem ein großes küchen zählt das
noch aus der zeit der kulturrevolution
zu stammen scheint
wir sind gerade dabei zu prüfen aber
alles dabei ist das ist vermutlich das
essenszelt wir haben hier die extra
leichten heringe und auch die anderen
sachen sind super leicht das zelt muss
um die 50 kilo schwer sein mit den
stangen in einem hinterzimmer ihrer
unterkunft hat sebastian ein treffen mit
dem kontaktmann der expedition
vereinbart
david hat bereits mehrmals eine
ausländische expedition ins tian shan
gebirge geführt 20.000 us dollar
wechseln die hand ein vermögen ok jetzt
habe ich alles geld damit gibt es für
euch keine probleme mehr auf eine gute
zusammenarbeit
das hier ist alles für die reise alles
wird bezahlt damit die bewilligungen
unser essen alles das wird schon klappen
hat schon fünf expeditionen begleitet
wir hatten kontakt mit dem leiter einer
expedition die ihn engagiert hatte er
hat gesagt dass ein guter typ
ich denke also nicht dass er nur mit
unserer kohle abhaut
der rest des teams besorgt sich
unterdessen proviant für die busreise
diese zum ausgangspunkt ihrer expedition
bringen wird
[Musik]
l'aquila
doch der fußball nicht so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
grüße keine rolle was genau ich habe
[Musik]
ja im moment sondern viel gefühl ich
freu mich drauf des monats der stand mit
mega wetter und es stinkt mega aber ja
mir ist der fall das land eine disco in
der großstadt und jetzt glaube es sind
alle froh dass man jetzt endlich eine
stadt unserer richtung berge
[Musik]
m3 tragen will das team von urumqi nach
kroatien reist im letzten vorposten der
zivilisation vor dem tian shan gebirge
[Musik]
wie in ganz china ist auch ein cinch an
der bauboom ein sichtbares zeichen einer
stark wachsenden wirtschaft
[Musik]
wie hoch genau warum
zwischenhalt in ely roman hary
inspiziert das lokale angebot an
medikamenten
als mitglied der schweizerischen
gesellschaft für geburtsmedizin ist der
arzt für die medizinische versorgung der
expedition zuständig
interessant da muss man sich schon
bewusst ist ja behaupten ist später also
wenn man vom wenn man einen unfall hat
vom basecamp buß ist es wahrscheinlich
gute dauert bis eine halbe minister
trage und hass ist normal sagt selber
acht stunden gute straße besucher so
viele und jeweils mit der gute versorgen
die hauptausstellung wenn man zweifel
letztlich komplett ist nicht realistisch
das ist es gibt so herrlich schiene vom
militär frauen aber die berühmten
einfach nicht kältestarre möglichkeit
der genetik mit hell ist aber die darf
natürlich nicht glücklich in china und
taiwan rücktransports erscheine halbtag
eine zone mit oder die aus teilen ein
bilanzposten funktionieren noch viel
wasser die variationsmöglichkeiten
der bus bewegt sich zermürbend langsam
durch die landschaft
[Musik]
immer weiter bringt die
reisegesellschaft in den wilden westen
chinas vor
[Musik]
nach drei tagen fahrt und ein paar
hindernissen erreicht das team endlich
das tor zum nationalpark vor dem tian
shan gebirge
[Musik]
letzteres ist kino gibt mindestens zwei
dosen mit
aber jetzt haben wir uns auch von
außerhalb des
[Musik]
hot springs der letzte bewohnte flecken
vor der großen wildnis noch sind ein
paar missverständnisse aus dem weg zu
räumen
du kaufst mehr brot du bezahlst für das
frühstück um fürs mittag und abendessen
weißt du es war völlig okay dass wir in
der stadt für das essen gesorgt haben
von hier an ist es aber ein teil der
organisation
ja klar du hast hier essen gekauft der
eine sorge alles ist bereit das ist
meine frage das essen ist hier alles ist
hier
[Musik]
und tatsächlich
der branche zu mir aber einfach so im
hals in den schnee tief in die mega
durlangen
richtig auf
[Applaus]
der besitzer der jurte ist persönlich
darum besorgt dass den schweizern
während der nacht warm ist
[Musik]
vielleicht ja ja wenn man nicht gerecht
von dieser schuld positiv das ziel rückt
näher
noch einmal besprechen die jungs ihre
pläne die bevorzugten routen die berge
die sie erklimmen wollen
[Musik]
der track der die lasten in space camp
im tien shan gebirge transportieren wird
setzt sich aus 22 pferden und einem
halben dutzend reiter zusammen
wird bei einem ist ganz gepackt rasse
verladen und nach erwarte man ist
traurig weil ich glaube dass ihr bestand
und erwachsene ist so erwartet dort
campieren mit dem schlafsack atv ist je
nach dem in der jurte klafft da luxus
seinen ring nach einem und ahlmann hatte
mit den space kein pro 19 5 stunden
[Musik]
das war gar nichts
oder frauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was erreicht und ist gott sagen sie
langsam richtig basecamp ja das sieht
man das erstmal studie anfänglich
imposantes
[Musik]
hier auf 3500 meter über meer werden die
bergsteiger für die nächsten drei wochen
leben und von hier aus ihre touren ins
gebirge unternehmen eine von zwei
kilometer breiter zerklüfteter gletscher
trend das basecamp von kilian fängt dem
eigentlichen ziel ihrer expedition
dort gibt es weder vegetation noch
frisches wasser
deshalb bauen sie das kennt auf diesen
flecken grasland mit einem nahe
gelegenen fluss auf eine kleine oase
inmitten der unwirtlichen
steinlandschaft
so ist weiß nicht aber so schlecht nicht
sein genie
jetzt habt ihr denn hätte dies nur
einmal gezeigt
[Musik]
noch ein erinnerungsfoto dann machen
sich die reiter auf den weiten weg
zurück nach hot springs
[Musik]
mit schlechtem wetter haben die
schweizer bergsteiger gerechnet aber
dass es mitten im juli schneit ist dann
doch eine überraschung
das brauche nur einen tag bis es trocken
ist
[Applaus]
das war das
frisch wechselhaft aber das spielt nicht
so eine rolle
ich glaube lehrt wie schlecht das wetter
jetzt perfekt weiter und kommen wieder
mal thematisiert schlechtes wetter den
wir aus mir grad mehr aufregen
das satellitentelefon ist die einzige
verbindung zur außenwelt
es dient vor allem dazu per
textnachricht die wetterprognose zu
erhalten
geschnitten
ich hab' ich gerade gelesen wurde und
von der hochsommerliche wintereinbruch
dauert mehrere tage
dann klart es auf und das kern schaan
gebirge präsentiert sich in seiner
ganzen majestätischen schönheit
die schweizer wollen sich mit einer
mehrtägigen akklimatisationstour auf die
höhe vorbereiten die sich später beim
aufstieg zum 6500 meter hohen expedition
szili anfang überwinden müssen
roman hary höhen mediziner und selbst
leidenschaftlicher bergsteiger will
dabei überprüfen wie die teilnehmer auf
die ungewohnte höhe reagieren
der junge wurde sogar schon großartig
und ich glaube das ist vom schwierigsten
aus wahlwies audel muss effizient und
ballert sie zum lehre dass man inhalte
langsame desto besser das morgen im
oberlauf auch wenn man 500 meter pro
strommarkt dass man natürlich mit 250
und selbstorganisation verbessert
[Musik]
so hat das team dennoch um bestiegenen
gipfel respektvoll getauft
damit ihre körper genügend zeit haben
sich auf die höhe einzustellen wollen
sie den berg in mehreren etappen
bezwingen nach einer ersten nacht im
biwak werden sie wieder ins base camp zu
erklären
am späten nachmittag erreicht das team
den ersten biwakplatz in aller eile
brauchen die jungs ihre zelte auf
[Musik]
man sagt sich auf hindi heimlich würde
china hoffe jetzt geht's sehr gute
gulasch
am ursprung marie
[Musik]
das wetter im tian shan gebirge ist
launenhaft gegen abend scheint bereits
wieder die sonne und das team ändert für
den nächsten tag den plan nicht
funktioniert und sei das nächste zeit
gehört sind und folgende fünf wahren
schlacht sie mit temperatursturz und
viel niederschlag und daher eigentlich
alonso an china verloren gezogen spies
kampfpausen probieren der gipfels machen
1200 höhenmeter in einem tag ein
gewagter entscheid auf halben weg wollen
sie ein biwak errichten das ihnen als
nachtlager dient wenn sie den gipfel
dann erreicht haben die jungs sind noch
längst nicht richtig akklimatisiert aber
der berg ruft und lockt und sie wollen
endlich ihren ersten bestiegenen gipfel
erobern
sind von morgens das expeditionsteam hat
einen strengen tag vor sich und einen
ersten test was die höhe mit ihnen
ansteht und wieder überrascht sie das
tian shan wetter
dann brauchen wir hilfe genommen
[Musik]
noch 300 höhenmeter bis zum dementi
langsam macht sich die dünne luft
bemerkbar
die alte männer stapfen die jungs durch
den schnee und kämpfen um jeden meter
pilze haben sind ist aber mit meinen
strom für firmen gering
[Applaus]
wie geht es hinten
diese einsparungen auch über das sie
geht mit kopf trinken
danke
[Musik]
jetzt spüre ich die höhe
jetzt erst weiter unten wo her ging es
gut
ein bisschen kopfweh herbig
[Musik]
endlich haben sie geschafft wovon jeder
bergsteiger sein leben lang träumt auf
einem gipfel zu stehen denn noch nie
zuvor von einem menschen bezwungen wurde
[Musik]
es ist cool als erster hier oben zu sein
aber die traverse zeigt warum wir die
ersten waren bis vor dem gipfel ging es
gut aber dann gab es viele dächten es
ist voll davon und wir müssen die
ostflanke wieder durchqueren zwischen
eis und schnee da nicht hielt ich bin
froh wenn ich wieder unten an einem ort
bin wo wir diese schwierigkeiten los
sind weil hier auf 5400 metern ist es
echt krass
der schnelle aufstieg ist an keinem der
jungen bergsteiger spurlos vorüber
gegangen
nach der kommenden nacht im biwak werden
sie noch so gerne wieder zum base camp
hinunter steigen
david weiß genau was die jungs nach
ihrer rückkehr brauchen zeit
dollar
hmm
[Musik]
cool
im kopf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
naja
vor 42 ohne akklimatisiert der architekt
offizier das ist er eigentlich schnell
wurde und damit sprechen herr ausbau von
60 deutlich gemerkt was das bedeutet und
das ist sich nowak foxi oder farbig die
ganze sache auch realistisch was los ist
ich hoffe dass seine dynamik aber das
macht ja irgendwie der schlachten einmal
bricht stecken die eigentlich nach
gefühlt und auch in ungarn kann bei
überstunden tropfen kann und machen so
bei menschen verschenkt nichts mit
amazon und dann wies nur vergessen
und jetzt möchte ich sehr gut und das 20
mal passiert wie sie sehen auf 2 gb und
den ist nicht das ziel ist wenn ich mal
also kreativ machen aber größer höher
sondern periodische arm ich das nicht
zustehen absetzen und damit schnell viel
gegeben da gibt es vielleicht einmal zu
viel
die terroristen es geht jetzt geht und
nach die zuständigen schon viel sparen
wie würden sie sagen langsam baut muss
einfach entspannend weil die geht es im
leben
die ärztin arabiens kommt mit einem
nachschub dreck in space camp um ihren
kollegen roman harry abzulösen
beide betreuen die expedition
ehrenamtlich stabsübergabe der höhen
mediziner
der onkel mein ebook stores in 14
städten dachte dass ich habe das
dokument dafür gespart weil solche
konzepte verfügen über medizinische
intervention der zwille anfängt das
nächste ziel nach der rund zweiwöchigen
akklimatisation phase überlegten batman
peak noch einmal um mehr als 1000 meter
für seine besteigung muss das
expeditionsteam zuerst einige maßnahmen
für die sicherheit treffen
als erstes wollen sie einen weg über den
gletscher zwischen basecamp und dem fuß
des quali anfang vorbereiten
mit seinen spalten und dem losen geröll
ist dieses gelände nicht ungefährlich
zudem brauchen sie ein gut ausgerüstetes
lager auf der gegenüberliegenden seite
des gletschers in dem sie material
deponieren und notfalls übernachten
können
jetzt gilt es die route zum gipfel zu
wählen
zum ersten mal in der bei dreijährigen
geschichte des expeditionsteams gibt es
meinungsverschiedenheiten krank die
schwere gestellt in roth rief bringen
wir profi verbänden und irgendwie links
durch die ganze gletscherabbruch wer
bist du vermutlich erzählungen
immobilien jetzt donnerstag wir sie in
eine gruppe der gerne auch mal vorschlag
genau aber ich sagen dass der router da
ist irgendwie zwei jahre und wir sind
noch nicht im gewinn für das und mit was
wir da gemacht haben
das ist alles vorbereitet thematisieren
kann verbunden und abstieg als abstände
reinmachen in der wand wenn es schneit
was gesehen wie es ist diese band jack
war ja aber wir kommen sogar recht hier
der tag ich habe nach dem start hinten
runter wenn du hinten liegen in der
linie machst man muss ja auch der
gezwungenermaßen abseilen aber sind es
noch zum schauen aber ja klar das ist ja
absolut
irgendwie auf die show berufe java
verschuldete schnell gerufen da dort
sieht das schnell die sehr gute ich
denke jetzt vielleicht wechselt aber das
wie ein traum
das mega realistisch ohne erfahrung
ich weiß was aber durch die länger du
verstehst nicht ganz tolles gefühl du
erinnerst wie du warst
ja aber gut begründet und davon
trotz dicker luft hat sich das team auf
eine gemeinsame gute geeinigt die
vorarbeiten gehen weiter
denn noch einmal richtig gletscher
hintere problem
die erste stufe niedrigsten waren damit
der schwächste runde
denn das ist wichtig und richtig wäre
doch dahinter
das team will fixseile beim einstieg der
geplanten route zum gipfel des quelle
anfang an bringen
sie sollen dazu dienen die besonders
langwierige einstiegs passage rasch zu
überwinden
nikola hat nach wie vor massive bedenken
über die machbarkeit gute
die situation am hang ist mit risiken
behaftet die vom basecamp aus nicht
erkennbar war dass sie keinen sinn macht
weil immer wieder das betrifft und
lawinen herunterkommt
[Musik]
am schluss war es wirklich war es
gefährlich da im süden sind uns ziemlich
große dinge auf den kopf gefallen
die ursprünglichen pläne zur begehung
des quelle anfang sind nicht
durchführbar aber der rückschlag ist für
das expeditionsteam kein grund
aufzugeben
wir haben unser ursprüngliches projekt
begraben
es wäre eine erstbesteigung auf über
6000 meter gewesen
aber wir haben mehrere lawinen gesehen
und es hat der gletscherspalten von dem
pulver durch das wir hätten klettern
müssen um hinauf zu kommen morgen soll
es noch mal schlechtes wetter geben und
ich hoffe dass es nachher möglich sein
wird endlich die expedition fortzuführen
und die großen monster zu attackieren
die seit zwei wochen auf uns warten
[Musik]
das team hat einen neuen plan gefasst
die jungs werden sich aufteilen und zwei
verschiedene gipfel angehen so können
sie die unterschiedlichen wünsche und
fähigkeiten von allen berücksichtigen
nicolas lukas wollen den west knacken
[Musik]
die route des anderen teams ist nicht
weniger ambitioniert nächsten tag
er hat uns eigentlich ins bett kam
der wetterbericht sagt fünf schöne tage
voraus morgen früh soll es losgehen
ein grund den schweizer fondue käse aus
dem gefrierschrank zu holen
es gibt ein planer kronen und die jungs
übernehmen den kosten ist können wir
nudeln haben
hier habe ich welche diejenigen welche
macht ja dann kommt alles in einer
pfanne
[Musik]
recht gut du musst probieren da es gibt
ihr kraft für viele monate
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich genieße
für ein gutes gelingen wird bis spät in
die nacht den bösen geist des tian shan
gebirges der garaus gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
st
heute ist es endlich soweit die
schweizer wollen die gipfel der berge
textile anfängen angriff nehmen
sollte ich diese aktion bei der man das
nicht
so
oder
wie für aus nachts
als proviant für den ersten tag des
aufstiegs koch david gemüse reis
die beiden seilschaften machen sich
bereit für den abmarsch die eine gruppe
um expeditionsleiter danny wilde
nordgipfel erreichen
[Musik]
nicola und lukas planen die erstbegehung
desks melián west
der schlachthof lassen 4000 zu müssen
auf ihre anrufe und zu müssen
nach spuren patrick niederlage
beide gruppen geben sich vier bis fünf
tage zeit um ihr ziel zu erreichen
so lange soll das angekündigte
schönwetterfenster andauern
das gelingen expedition ärztin nora
pions bleibt im basecamp und wird mit
dem team sporadisch per funk kontakt
[Musik]
der erste tag ist für das team west
vergleichsweise einfach
nicola und lukas steigen heute nur 500
meter hoch und wollen auf 4000 meter
über meer übernachten
der nächste tag wird dafür umso strenger
1200 höhenmeter an der steilen schnee
und eisbedeckten westflanke des wlan
west stehen ihm bevor
[Musik]
im lager 15 julian westermann direkt
direkt und ohne handicap dass man immer
mehr
und wenn ich mir sehr gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber egoistisch und verliebt das ist mal
ein richter sie für rechtsstaatlich und
links familie das gibt er gleich zweimal
optimismus
[Musik]
team nord hat sich für den ersten tag
mehr vorgenommen ihr erstes bieber
gerichten sie auf 4600 metern höhe
ich glaube die anderen sind da unten auf
der moräne beim lawinenkegel baby du
suchst eine gute versuche das licht der
biwakplatz ist sicher es gibt keine
gletscherspalten unter der schneedecke
hat ihre ganz gut gemacht aber sie lässt
eingeschaltet hat aber du hast die
funken gestattet
super gute nacht morgen wird das wetter
bombastisch wie nora sich ausdrückte
also bereit zum weitermachen
wir erwarten dass der schnee morgen hart
ist dass es gefriert dann kommen wir
etwas besser vorwärts
heute sind wir bis zu den oberschenkeln
eingesunken begeben um sich gegenseitig
war das sind zu viert und das geht echt
gut
morgendämmerung am west gratis-wlan fing
lukas und nicola gleichen zum zweiten
tag ihres gipfels sturms auf 1200
höhenmeter eis und schnee klettern
liegen vor ihm
eine tour de force vor allem für nicola
der bereits auf den akklimatisationstour
in die höhe schlecht vertragen hat
ein blick zurück auf ihr werk beweist
sie haben gefährlich geschlafen und
trotzdem richtig entschieden
die lawine donnert auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite ihres nacht
lagers in den talkessel
[Musik]
einige wirklich wirken mit
im basecamp hat nora einen
überraschenden gast roman ist nach der
ersten nacht am berg zurückgekehrt weil
ihm eine kleine verletzung die
weiterführung der tour vermasselt hat
im moment ist das problem in 73 ländern
sind schwierig sagen ist das ist
wirklich und maschinen
krebs in zusammenhang steht mit ok
[Musik]
es schaut dann wird passieren
[Applaus]
die verbleibenden mitglieder der
seilschaft maximilian ort setzen den
aufstieg ohne roman fort wir sind nun im
couloir auf über 4900 meter hoch
gestiegen
ja gut gespurt
es ist steil nicht erst eine große wand
sicher 700 meter von unten sei es kürzer
aus
wir freuen uns wenn wir uns ausruhen
können
das alles haben wir gemacht jetzt sind
wir langsam kaputt
dort unten ist das basecamp das ist ganz
und gar nicht schlecht ist hoch dieses
ding nicht man spürt die höhe
das soll bis zum abstieg muss wegen
gegen die em mega gegend werden wünscht
man sich im ersten moment denken wieder
seinen lehrern einsteiger auf der haupt
da sind wir dass das wenigstens sicher
ist wo man gesehen wo man merkt ja
logisch aber negativ denkbar schlechten
start energie noch eine krise und den 21
das ganze war die erste expedition
venture einen fünftel gestiegen
die innerhalb drei sieger machen als
erste das so genial glaube die meisten
sachse
am quälen west quälen sich lukas und
nicola zu ihrem zweiten biwakplatz hoch
sie bekommen mit voller wucht zu spüren
was es heißt in dieser höhe unterwegs zu
sein
[Musik]
das team um du nie hat sich einen
speziell lauschigen biwakplatz auf 5600
metern höhe ausgesucht wir sind gut
organisiert
wir essen die teller nicht leer wir
schlafen am tisch das sind zustände hier
gute nacht bis morgen kinder sagt auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
für lukas und nicola ist der tag noch
nicht zu ende
sie sind auf der suche nach einem biwak
platz für die nacht
nicola kann nicht mehr
und hatte fünfeinhalb deutschen markt
noch 550 meter trennen lukas und nicola
vom gipfel des queen west sie hoffen
dass sie sich über nacht ein wenig
erholen können
[Musik]
wieso richtungen
[Applaus]
ja und besser wird auf der region zu
kommen
[Musik]
wenn die wirtschaftlichkeit hat skoda
keine rücksicht ist der ccc eine station
ist ja aber wir sind das team doch nicht
[Musik]
einzelkämpfer der sein geld in die
vertikale blieb der mit zimmer aber die
nicht so und dann bin ich wieder indes
dass ich hier ist das überhaupt noch gar
kein schlechtes chris h vielleicht
einfach so ein verschlag größten tätig
aber schlecht zusammen nico sache
entscheide
die pläne würden
[Applaus]
die codes die eigentlich recht gut
wieder
also roma-kinder damit jeden morgen
abstiege okay der shop zum kehre gute
nacht und auf was du nicht abstieg okay
gut danke für mal dem fall bis will ich
mal
die beiden jungen bergsteiger haben ihr
ziel nicht erreicht aber sie haben
erfahren dass freundschaft ebenso
erfüllt sein kann wie das erstürmen
eines gipfels
[Musik]
die seilschaft maximilian nord es ist
bereits abend und außergewöhnlich spät
um noch am berg unterwegs zu sein
sebastian dilly und sebastian kämpfen
immer noch um jeden meter
[Musik]
um zehn uhr abends stehen die
bergsteiger auf dem gipfel
gerade rechtzeitig um zeuge des wohl
schönsten sonnenuntergangs ihres lebens
zu werden
[Musik]
sorry ich habe in der landschaft
für den lukas einer doch mappus kann mir
das nicht oft vorkommt und grundgehaltes
team und es gehört einfach dazu und
welchem schlag weiter
ich behaupte handlicher seile und
zusammenarbeiten
merck kg zum sprudeln sie gegen diese
tournee das nachbarhaus ihre minister
rechnet ist aber was ist also ob sie
mithilfe von aromen hat der auf der
probier auf den berg so und von einem
helfer wie das thema abstieg nicht mehr
sein dass in der 36 wie sich aus
rücksicht auf den gipfel so ja egal ob
es an den berggipfel erstangriff
gestiegen und der kerzenwerkstatt es ist
für die auch sehr große und lehre ich
die erfahrung mit der höhe und
miteinander immer reagiere die stelle
hab einmal galaxy 15
ich habe weniger titanic sie
und christa schluss auf und zahlt und
luke studierte luft und plötzlich ist
geschlossen teilt diese analogen und
auch das schon ich diesen umgegangen
das nächste
[Musik]
das leben
einmal mehr dass sich bestätigt es ist
der kopf der die letzte meile geht mein
team war super motiviert sie haben
entschieden den gipfel zu machen aber
die letzten 500 meter haben sie wird
sich mit sich gekämpft
ich habe mich in dieser nacht übergeben
dann auf ein paar mal tagsüber und am
fuß der wand
ich habe ihnen dann gesagt dass ich zu
schwach sei um das nicht schaffe und sie
haben gesagt wenn du motiviert bist dann
gehen wir raus
wir werden alles spuren und so gingen
sie voraus und ich folgte in meinem
tempo sie haben das super gemacht
am ende war es wirklich nur noch der
kopf der sie voranbrachte
[Musik]
neben streller vergibt aber wir sind
noch belohnt wurde im gletscher doch um
gipfel wunderschöne stimme flüchtet nun
freue ich mich aufs heimgehen
ich freue mich meine familie zu sehen
schweizer sachen zu essen schokolade
käse brot am meisten vermisst habe ich
natürlich meine freundin
[Musik]
sie haben toll gekämpft und das in ihrem
alter hut denn das ist normalerweise ein
alter in dem man zwar physisch sehr
stark ist aber eben nicht mental um den
da ausdauer
ich bin wirklich stolz auf sie
[Musik]
nach sechs langen wochen ist das
abenteuer zu ende
es war ein langer weg auf den sich das
expeditionsteam vor drei jahren gemacht
hat
[Musik]
essen
für die jungen bergsteiger und ihren
lied guide wird es nicht das letzte
abenteuer sein
sie werden wieder aufbrechen gemeinsam
oder mit anderen freunden die ihre
leidenschaft tränen
aber immer werden sie die bilder die
gefühle die momente der gefahren und der
erfolge diesem tian shan gebirge erlebt
haben mit sich tragen
[Musik]